notre focus du jour nous conduit
aujourd'hui en afghanistan depuis leur
prise d'assaut en août dernier les
talibans tentent de renvoyer une image
plus modérée au reste du monde ils
affirment qu'ils ont changé afin
d'obtenir la reconnaissance
internationale et un retour des aides
financières malgré ce changement
certains de rhétorique l'application de
la charia s'immisce toujours dans le
quotidien des habitants de kaboul voyez
un peu ce reportage signé maryse burgot
derrière les tissus à l'abri des regards
plusieurs têtes coupées de mannequin
le propriétaire du magasin les a
sectionné il ya quinze jours
après un ordre venu des talibans
les talibans nous ont dit que c'était
était contraire à la charia comme c'est
un peu comme lorsqu'il faisait exploser
les têtes de bouddha donc j'ai été
obligé de les enlever
dans ce centre commercial
l'ordre des fondamentalistes est
affichée sur les murs
selon leur interprétation stricte de
l'islam la représentation deux figures
humaines est interdit
[Applaudissements]
et dicté uniquement ici à harat
troisième ville d'afghanistan
une initiative des talibans locaux ils
ont un peu d'autonomie par rapport au
pouvoir central à kaboul
vous voyez ici on peut peut-être
diminuer la taille certains en revanche
refusent les ordres des talibans sept
autres propriétaires n'a pas accepté de
couper les têtes de ses mannequins pour
l'instant les talibans le laisse faire
ils passent devant son magasin mais ne
disent horaire tout ça ce n'est que le
début là il s'agit de couper des têtes
de mannequin mais ils iront plus loin
dhr demain vous verrez il d'internés
book encore plus de choses aux femmes
ils feront pas exactement comme il ya 20
ans quand il était au pouvoir
une résistance visible dans de nombreux
commerces comme si les talibans
n'avaient pas les moyens de faire
appliquer leurs lois
ici le propriétaire a opté pour une
demi-mesure pas de têtes coupées mais
des chapeaux en fourrure
à kaboul la capitale une autre forme de
résistance au quotidien ces affiches ont
été placardées à l'entrée des
restaurants et commerces
elle stipule que les femmes doivent
porter une tenue couvrante la burqa de
couleur bleue illustre le propos
mais comme les commerçants des rates les
fans de kaboul ne se laisse pas faire
même les femmes ont les mêmes droits que
les hommes on doit pouvoir porter ce que
l'on veut
je n'aime pas du tout cela je ne veux
même pas en entendre parler personne ne
m'obligera mais je refuse de porter ce
genre de tottenham
certaines femmes portent la burqa bien
sûr mais dans les restaurants comme dans
les rues les voiles colorées reste
beaucoup plus nombreux les talibans là
aussi les sphères il espère en fait la
reconnaissance de la communauté
internationale
ils sont donc obligés de modérer leurs
actions comme leur dise qu'on
nous explique la loi de dieu et de la
charia aux femmes si elles ne font pas
su de bison on ne veut pas les obliger
mais si dieu le veut avec le temps elles
changeront et l accepterons c est dans
la m et d'ailleurs dans les faits la vie
est déjà de plus en plus dur pour les
femmes de kaboul ces deux afghane
cherche un taxi depuis deux heures celui
ci pourtant libre
refuse de les prendre
les talibans demandent tout chauffeur de
ne pas accepter les passagères jugé
insuffisamment couvertes beaucoup
obtempère
la plupart des chauffeurs sont
terrorisés de laisser monter les femmes
parce qu'ils savent qu'ils n'ont pas le
droit de le faire
une peur qui conduit certains
commerçants de kaboul à supprimer tous
les visages sur leur vitrine
allez reste de l'actualité sportive
cette fois tout d'abord du tennis la
française alizé cornet a été éliminée de
l'open d'australie aux quarts de finale
échec face à l'américaine daniel collins